Dad, there are so many things to worry about,
whether he's kind, whether he's
polite, whether his private life is disordered,
how many kilos he can raise on the bench press
,
and so on.
Absolutely, my
seniors are
already
very serious, a
little too serious,
they look at my assignments,
I don't smoke, I don't drink much, my
hobbies are muscle training and games
I
don't have anything because
I'm different, so I'm just stuck in my senior's room Because
our tastes in games match, I play games.
I
forgot to correct it after I didn't do anything, but my
senior is
n't that
boyfriend, so I went to the house of a man who wasn't even a boyfriend, and played games
together and made dinner for the two of us.
Hana-chan, what
are you
doing?
It's not that
I love my senior, it's that my senior loves me